Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're talking about your legacy.
What?
When you go to a funeral,
sometimes, as I did recently,
it puts these things on
the forefront of your mind,
thinking about like, man, when I pass,
how am I gonna be remembered?
And is there something
that I should be doing now
in order to facilitate
my memory, or my legacy?
The first thing that comes to mind is
you should be trying to
find a way to get that image
of you peeing chocolate into my mouth
off of the internet before you die.
Yeah, and I do wanna talk about-
And I should actively also
be working towards that.
That should be our only goal.
Let's just stop this podcast right now.
I do wanna talk about us
as a special case in this,
but you know what?
Maybe you're not an internet celebrity.
Maybe you're just an avid listener
of two internet celebrities,
and that's okay.
You still need to tackle your legacy,
and how you wanna be remembered
is anything you can do.
So I think we can put ourselves
in the shoes of the listener
as well and talk about that,
because yeah, I have been
in this mode of, okay,
passing away, remembering-
You were in the mode of passing away?
Please.
No, I'm not passing away.
Technically, we all are slowly.
Yeah, I went to a funeral.
I'm in the head space-
Good, good word.
Of passing away and being remembered.
So I just thought, let's have
a conversation about that.
So I think the first half
is me sharing the experience
of everything surrounding this funeral.
And of course, I'm keeping it vague,
because once I start telling you about it,
I'll be telling you about it.
And then I do think there's
a specific discovery
that then really got me thinking
about all of this stuff.
Got you thinking?
More than just a funeral.
Okay.
More than just what other people say
about you after you die,
and a lot more about what you say
about yourself after you die.
Okay, talking about holograms now.
You're intrigued?
See, all this was teaser,
pretty lighthearted teaser.
I guess it's gonna
start out kind of heavy.
If you don't wanna hear
about passing of loved ones and funerals,
this is not the episode for you,
or role-playing your own death.
That's not, I'm not saying
that the right way either.
Anyway-
Proceed.
All right, hard left
turn into being serious.
As you know, I've talked
about it, I know you know,
but as I've talked about on Ear Biscuits,
my mom's husband Lewis
has not been good, good,
good for a long time.
Of course, that was his catchphrase.
But then once he suffered
a number of strokes
about three years ago,
we never heard him say
good, good, good anymore.
And I believe after I went home in July,
I came back and talked
about it on an Ear Biscuit,
my whole experience of going home.
If it wasn't that episode,
it was another one where
I was just really inspired
by my mom being so sacrificial
in her love for Lewis
to take care of him 24/7 as a nurse,
as well as a wife and companion for,
yeah, what went on for three years.
He had a number of health
complications recently,
and we were tracking along with mom,
and it was a bit of a
surprise when he passed,
but he had taken a turn.
So there was like, there were a few days,
maybe a week leading up to it.
He had some complications from COVID.
He had a number of other things going on.
But the long and short of
it is, he did pass away.
I never called Lewis my stepdad,
because again, he got married to mom.
You did call him your father-in-law.
I called, I always called
him my father-in-law,
because I loved him so much.
I definitely loved him.
And you know-
You feel like stepdad
is not endearing enough.
Yeah, I'm not feeling that term.
There should be a term
for when your stepdad steps
up and becomes your dad.
And I think you just call him dad.
Well, he didn't become my dad either.
Okay.
He just, he became-
'Cause you were an adult
already, when they got together.
He became my mom's husband after-
And that's how you're
always referred to him.
My mom's husband.
And everybody'd be like, "Your stepdad?"
Right.
And that's not to say
that I didn't love him,
and still do love him.
And he was a Popeye to my kids,
as well as a wonderful,
wonderful husband to my mom.
They loved each other.
The reason why, and you know what,
they gave people an opportunity
to stand up at the funeral
and say a little something about Lewis.
And I got up and I just-
And I have a firsthand account of this,
well, secondhand account,
because my-
Yeah, you weren't there.
My wife was there.
Yeah, that's right.
Because my wife happened to be
in North Carolina at the time.
Which was awesome.
Yeah, she was there.
I talked to her beforehand.
She said Link did great.
Just in case you had
any doubts about that.
Well, I knew there was
gonna be like a popcorn sharing time.
And I knew that I was
ready to go first, so that,
to prime the pump for other people to go.
Because they might not have
known and been prepared for it.
It's not walk up and go
behind the podium and talk-
It's just stand up
at your spot-
Just stand up where you are,
because the family just felt
like that would give people
an opportunity to say
something from the heart,
but not put anybody on the spot
who really needed to prepare
a eulogy.
No microphones involved.
There was a microphone.
A passive mic.
So I knew that this was gonna happen.
And so I was ready to
kind of prime the pump.
So I stood up first and
said my little piece,
and then other people said their thing,
but I did a very calculated,
I'm not going to ramble on forever,
because then other people
will feel like they have to do that.
And a lot of me getting up,
and the main reason I'm
getting up is obvious.
But a secondary reason I'm getting up is
to empower other people to
share what's on their heart,
by not being too long or too perfect
or intimidating or anything.
I'm just gonna be myself
and keep it simple.
Okay.
But also keep it quick.
And that was the one thing
that I knew could be a problem.
How long did you go?
Longer than I wanted,
but I think it ended up being like,
it felt like four minutes, so
it was probably six minutes.
Probably seven and a half.
And it could have been seven and a half,
but like Jessie told you-
You did great.
I did great.
But I was really glad to celebrate
he and mom's relationship,
and the things that I had already shared
with you and shared on this podcast
that it really was a representation of,
a fulfillment of the
marriage vows they took,
in sickness and in health,
till death to us part.
She was there with him.
She went above and beyond, not as a wife,
but as a nurse, really, to care for him,
when she had lost so
much of him years ago.
I's been so difficult to see
both of them go through this,
but I say, you know what?
She didn't do it as a
fulfillment of her vows.
She did it because she loved him.
They had a great relationship.
They had a great life together.
They enjoyed each other.
And it's a beautiful thing that he was,
the way he treated her
and the companionship
they gave each other,
he was worthy of the
care that she gave him.
And that was the way that
I wanted to honor him
to his family and
friends there was to say,
I'm celebrating my mom for what she did
in service to him out of love,
not out of obligation.
And I'm so glad that she
had someone in her life
that was worthy of that
type of care and sacrifice,
because Lewis was an awesome guy.
He was loved by everybody
in the community.
That's why other people
wanted to say something.
The service was really beautiful,
and it was a celebration.
It made all of us feel very grateful
to have had him in our lives.
I will also say another note
that I got from Jessie about this funeral.
I didn't know if you were gonna talk
about this aspect of it.
We've been to many Christian,
maybe only Christian
funerals in our lives.
And I know that this
was a Christian funeral
and they went to a Methodist Church.
In many of the funerals
that we went to growing up,
it was much less about the person
and they made it about
the people in the audience
and about them having to
make a decision about Jesus,
and it became this very
hardcore gospel presentation.
And it was kind of like, yeah,
he was a great dude, but what about you?
And where are you gonna spend eternity?
And we always felt like
it wasn't a real funeral
if the pastor didn't take
that hard turn into a gospel presentation.
And I was happy, the current
Rhett, not maybe the old Rhett,
but the current Rhett
was very happy to hear
that while obviously it
was a Christian message,
but it was really a
celebration of his life
and remembering him.
It was,
I believe it was honoring to
God and honoring to his faith,
and it was also honoring to his life.
And it wasn't putting the congregation
on the spot in any way,
which can feel kind of cringey.
So yeah, it really was
a beautiful service.
Exploiting someone's death
for the sake of an agenda.
I'll get off my soapbox. But
I'm just happy to hear that-
Yeah, that didn't happen.
Pastor did a great job, and
everybody else who talked,
including me, apparently.
Yeah, Link did great.
The pastor did great.
Come to think of it,
she didn't say anybody
didn't do great, so-
Yeah, everybody did great.
That's not really what
it was about, but sure.
But the experience around it was one
that I wouldn't trade for the world,
because Lewis passed away
on a Wednesday evening.
And then I got on a plane the next morning
to fly home to be with mom.
So within 22 hours of his
passing, I was there with mom.
So he died on a Wednesday night.
And then I was able to get on a plane
the next morning and fly home,
so that by 22 hours later,
I was there with my mom.
And we actually had plans to, as a family,
we were coming in,
we had already made plans a long time ago
to come into town the following weekend
for Britton's wedding,
which was basically in the
next town over in Sanford.
So we were like, okay,
we all need to be here for the funeral.
We may not be able to make the wedding.
but it worked out with the family
and the funeral home and everything
to push the funeral to
the following Thursday.
So he died on a Wednesday.
I arrived the next day.
One week later is when
we scheduled the funeral,
so that my family could come
into town, go to the funeral,
and then stay through the wedding
as opposed to missing the wedding,
because we couldn't do
both if it was earlier,
'cause they would be in jeopardy
of missing too much school.
So logistically, we worked that out,
but a byproduct of that,
and that's just something
that I'll end up treasuring
forever I think is
it meant that I was with
my mom for six days,
all day, and then staying
at her house all night,
until Christy and the kids showed up.
And then we went to an Airbnb
for the night before the funeral.
And that turned out to be,
it was great to be able
to be there for mom
and for it not to be
something that was rushed.
It's like when a loved one
dies across the country,
you go out there, but then you
gotta get back to your life,
and you can't keep doing
a lot of your work,
and so you gotta go back,
versus if you're in town,
you can show up and leave.
With us being over here,
it's just one of those times
where it really hurts to not be there
because you can't be there
for the people that you love the most.
So it was nice that it worked out.
And it was actually easier because it was,
that same week is the week
that you were on that trip with Locke.
So the same time that you were doing that.
That's why Jessie was there,
but you weren't there.
If anybody's wondering that.
And it made it easier logistically.
Our shooting schedule was kind of cleared.
And it ended up,
so I really felt released
from my work in a way
that I think I would've
made the right decision
to be with mom anyway,
maybe that whole time,
but I just felt more, I didn't
have the pressure of like,
okay, there's so much that
runs through the two of us.
I always get scared when it's
like, to do the right thing,
it's gonna make things really
hard back here for work.
So it was nice to be released from that,
because it just so happened you
were already gone that week.
And I helped mom walk through
a lot of the logistics
in working with Lewis's
family to like, I don't know,
just to set things up, keep
things clean around the house.
My mom's an only child, I'm an only child.
So when it comes to her
in our side of the family,
it's really just the two of us.
There's nobody else who's gonna
come in and help my mom out
except for a couple of her best friends
who are gonna be in and out.
So I did really need to step up.
So I was able to do that.
But every night,
people were coming through
all throughout the day,
but it was really every night,
people would stop showing
up when it got dark.
And it would just be the
two of us hanging out,
watching television, eating some more
of that Bojangles that
everybody was dropping off.
That's what people do, man.
Oh man, it was great.
Bojangles has this
cinnamon twist thing now.
It's like Bo-Berry
Biscuits are not as good
as this cinnamon twist thing they got.
Oh, okay, hold on.
People were bringing
these cinnamon twists by.
That might be sacrilegious.
I'm just planting a seed, man.
Nothing with cinnamon in it is
better than a Bo-Berry Biscuit.
It's just, oh, it's so good.
Okay.
But I had both.
So we'd be eating some of that.
Of course, I did go to the grocery store
and buy my supplies, which were-
Water, ChapStick.
Coffee and cereal.
So I'd get me a bowl of cereal,
and I'd sit down there with my mom.
Your mom's not a coffee drinker?
No, so I got to make sure I got my coffee.
Wow, she's never been a coffee drinker.
Nope.
And then we would just sit
down and talk every night.
Of course, we would talk,
she'd be processing,
this slowly becoming real.
You're in shock.
It's like, you might think it
was expected, but it wasn't,
and you really can't fully
expect to lose your mate.
So you can't be fully prepared for that.
So whenever she wanted
to talk about Lewis,
and memories or what they
had just been going through.
I was just able to listen.
But then we would also
talk about other things.
I brought up stuff like
memories from my childhood
that I was talking about in therapy.
I would bring up, I was like,
"Mom, I remember this thing."
I'm not gonna share it here.
But yeah, I kind of got
her perspective on it.
I don't care, I'll share it.
I remember when I was a kid, I would,
one of my first memories
was at First Baptist Church,
I got, it was me and Jimmy, my stepdad.
He was legitimately
my stepdad.
Your father-in-law.
Now my father-in-law.
Your first father-in-law.
I remember in the middle of the service,
I was doing something.
He took me out of the service
and walked down the center aisle
and took me out and gave me a lecture,
and then brought me back in
to apologize to my mom during the service.
And I don't even remember
what I was doing,
but I remember just kind
of being traumatized
by the fact that I was paraded
out in the middle of church,
and back in while everybody
was looking at me.
And it was like-
He didn't whoop you though.
He didn't whoop me.
And mom reminded me.
"Well, when you came back in,
you had a flower in your hand.
You'd picked a flower and
you came and gave it to me."
And I was like four years old.
Five years old at most.
And she was reminding me of that.
Pick a flower for your mama, boy.
Yeah, and she was like-
I don't care, just get one.
She gave me some insight
into what was going on there
that we had never talked about.
We had this very adult conversation about,
what was it, so many
things that, experiences,
these little bits and memories
that you have when you're a child,
that I never sat down
and picked my mom's brain
on what was happening
that, what did I do wrong?
Did she remember?
She said I couldn't sit still.
And she thought that the
punishment didn't fit the crime.
So there was a bit of vindication there,
but that's just the nature
of the type of conversations
that we ended up having to
the point where I was like,
maybe it was the first
night or the second night,
I just turned to mom and I was like,
"You know, this is the first time
that we've ever spent
this much time together
just the two of us since,
definitely before I got married."
Once I got married, I'm
always bringing Christy.
It's like, hey, we're,
I'm not coming and spending the night
with my mom once I'm a married man.
It just doesn't happen.
Well, in some relationships, it happens.
Yeah, but-
Not in yours though.
Yeah, I'm grateful for that.
And it's like, and we never,
and back when we did live together,
we were never having adult conversations.
So it was nice to be there for her,
but also to kind of have this,
to develop this new rapport
between the two of us.
Another time, I just
kind of got in my mind
questions I would ask her,
'cause it's, and I will clarify.
It's not that we weren't
close, but growing up,
it was just that-
Most people don't talk to their parents
about these things.
Yeah, she loved,
my mom was the sweetest mom.
I can't come up with any trash
to talk about her to my therapist.
I'll put it to you that way.
She never actively did
anything to me that I could,
that I need to pay for therapy for.
I could say that honestly.
But yeah, it's not like in college,
I called her and talked to
her on the phone all the time,
we had this dynamic relationship.
But we've always had a good relationship.
But this was kind of
like a different level
and a different facet to it,
which was surprising.
I started coming up with
questions to ask her like,
"Mom, what do you think
about me being famous?"
Just to get a kick out of
how she, and she was like,
"Why are you asking me that?"
She's getting paranoid, like,
"Do you think I'm not proud of you?"
I'm like, "No, no, no, I
know you're proud of me.
It's just like, do you-
Is it weird?
Do you, is it weird?
Do you actually know
that I'm, she was like,
"Well, I know that you're famous.
I do know that.
I go to the grocery store,
and people always have
something to say about you and Rhett."
And I'm like, okay, so
you don't really know.
I gotta take my mom
somewhere to prove my fame.
I don't know what it is.
Like when dad came out there that time
when we had the buddy system billboard,
I took him out on a Hollywood
Boulevard and was like,
"Look up there, see that billboard?
That's me in Hollywood.
That kind of did it for my dad.
Of course, he definitely knows I'm famous.
But that's the type of conversations
that mom and I were having.
And at some point in the
conversation, I remembered,
as we were talking about Lewis,
I was like, "You know what?
Lewis mentioned to me,
mom, do you know this?
I think he said it in front of you too
that he was writing down his life story."
Or I don't know how he put it.
I don't know if he said I'm
writing down my life story,
but in my mind it was like,
oh, Lewis is writing a memoir.
It's kind of how I processed it.
And she was like, "Yes.
I would give him such a
hard time about that."
Oh really?
He said, "I'm gonna write a book."
So many things have happened
to me, I'm gonna write a book.
And mom said, "And now I just kind of,
I feel kind of bad for him,
'cause I just gave him
a hard time about it.
I was like, "So you never read it?"
She was like, "No."
And it was like,
but the way that Lewis talked
about what he wrote was,
or that what he was writing was,
"I'm just writing down some stories from,
I got these stories,
things that happened to me.
I'm writing them down."
And so he would downplay.
He didn't say, "I'm writing
and gonna publish a book."
And I know I sound like Bill Clinton, but-
Well, so does he-
There's a little bit of-
Yeah, you sound like Lewis to me.
Okay, good.
So I went on his computer and-
I guess it was not password-protected.
No.
And I just started-
Well, if you're gonna write a memoir
and not keep it in the cloud,
then don't put a password
on your computer.
I don't think he has a cloud.
Exactly.
The cloud is the computer.
Yeah, Lewis didn't have a cloud.
I remember at the time,
and this was maybe a couple of years ago
that he mentioned this, that
I was thinking, wow, this,
if he's really following through with this
and he seems serious about it,
this is something that
one day when he does pass,
this will be a nice thing to have.
Maybe he's writing it for his
kids or, I haven't read it,
and he didn't say who
he was writing it for,
but that thought entered my
mind and kind of stuck in there.
And then it popped back in.
I was like, oh man, yeah, this is,
he's been working on this thing.
I know not in the past three years,
but before that, he would
say he was working on it.
So I went on his computer, and
I'll tell you what I found,
but first let's do an ad.
Doesn't this feel kind of cheap?
That's good.
You're gonna throw
the ads in-
I like that.
You might as well just throw them in
at a good cliffhanger.
I agree.
We want you to check out Stevie's podcast.
Best Friends-
If you have not done it.
Best Friends Back, Alright!
The podcast that she has with
her high school best friend,
they're reconnecting via podcast
in the episode that just came out is
all about how Stevie went from Stephanie,
yeah, that's the name
on her ID, to Stevie.
So there was a point in her high school
where she went from Stephanie to Stevie
and she talks about that.
And Neagheen talks about what it's like
to grow up with a name like Neagheen
in a place like Greensboro.
Yeah, so it's an episode all about them
processing their identity in high school,
and reprocessing it now as part
of them reprocessing their,
and rekindling their friendship.
So check it out if you like that,
if you like early 2000s nostalgia.
If you like voices other than ours,
they've got two great voices.
Yeah, they do.
Check it out, Best Friends Back, Alright!
wherever you get your podcast.
Mm-hm, all right.
So I'm looking on his desktop.
How do you search for this?
Well, first of all,
it's a Windows machine,
and I'm like, oh my gosh, what do I do?
It's like, look on the desktop
for just stuff that he's thrown there.
Memoir.
I don't know.
And somehow I found what I call a finder,
the Explorer window, the File Explorer.
I haven't used Windows in so long.
And I searched by date edited,
'cause I thought it might
be one of the last things,
it was an ongoing thing he worked on.
Maybe one of the last things he worked on.
And I'm looking at all the file names
and it's stuff like coaching tips.
And then there'd be things,
instead of naming it,
it would be like the first
word of the document,
like a lot of Word documents
where it would be like,
don't quit until,
and it would be like the
start of inspirational quotes
would be the names of these files.
'Cause he was a coach
for a really long time.
Yes.
And I started opening-
And a pretty successful coach
in several sports, right?
Yeah.
And I've got proof of that
that I'll get to in a second.
But yeah, he would, as a very
committed basketball coach,
he coached other things
too, but he accumulate,
I would start opening these things,
and it would be quotes,
inspirational quotes.
And first I thought he
was searching the internet
for inspirational quotes and
putting them in Word documents.
But what he was doing was
pulling from his memory
of coaching and working
under other coaches
and being so committed
to the craft of coaching
that he had all these
pithy inspirational sayings
that then he would just, from memory,
just start writing them
down in Word documents.
And then he would write things like,
he would write his own name,
and then he would write
like, what's it called?
Like an anagram?
An acrostic.
An acrostic, not an anagram.
He didn't worship Satan.
That's pentagram, but-
Oh, pentagram.
Yeah, so he did all
these Word document-esque
inspirational coaching exercise-
With his own name?
He even did his own name.
Wow, do you remember that one?
I'll have to look it up.
That's awesome.
I know.
It just says a lot about
who he was as a person
that he was just putting down to paper
all of these things that he would say
on the basketball court
to his teams and stuff.
Lovely, excellent, wonderful,
intelligent, and swell.
That's Lewis.
I didn't email that one to myself.
And then I came to one
that was called time line.
Time space line, not timeline,
two words, time line.
I said, this might be
it, and I opened it up.
And lo and behold, here
was a Word document.
It had a table of contents
at the top with years,
1967, 1969, 1972.
And it would say, okay,
this is when he was in college.
This is when he was in service.
This is when he had his first job.
So it was like a table of contents.
And then it was just,
then you go down beneath
it and it would be like,
okay, 1968, and then he
would have a paragraph.
Sometimes three paragraphs,
sometimes one sentence.
And then he would go to the next one,
1969, or whenever the
next date would show up.
And so he talked about
all types of things.
And I would just love to share
a few of the things that
I found in his timeline.
Oh, this is great.
Because it just shows you
the type of person he was,
that at the very beginning, he
gave an intro, it said 2017.
So it was like 1968, 2017.
It was like, "Now, before I
go any further on all this,
I wanna come back up here and write this."
So it's like,
you could tell he had
written the whole thing.
It was like four, it wasn't a tome.
This thing was like four or
five pages of Word documents.
He was sketching out stuff that
could be made into a memoir.
Right, okay.
But he went back up to the top, 2017,
and he was like, "Now,
I want you to remember,
it's not really about all
of the," how did he put it?
"It's not really about
all the things I did,
even though I experienced a lot of things.
It's about all the people
I met along the way.
And so pay special attention
to the people I met."
And then as you go
through the whole thing,
it wasn't his entire life.
It was kind of like if you were
writing a book for coaches.
It was like, the highlights of his life
related to basketball,
coaching, some about teaching,
and then a few stories
that he's told to people
over the years that he
wanted to put down on paper.
Time line, a coach's life.
Yeah, but it was more of,
it seemed like the audience,
definitely, his kids would enjoy it,
and they did get a copy of
it, but it was almost like-
And did they know that
this had been happening?
No.
Wow, that's really cool
that they didn't know
that this was happening.
Yeah, I was able to-
And you just remember that.
I was able to tell them, find
it, and email it to them.
And what I did was, I'll say, I found it.
I've read enough to know that this was it.
And then I stopped reading,
and I emailed it to them.
And I said, here it is.
This is the thing.
I didn't read all of it, but, period.
And I'm not gonna share it
with anybody else, except mom.
And then they wrote back
and said, please read it.
Please read it. And I'm not
gonna read the whole thing here.
I'm gonna read some excerpts.
You're saying you decided
not to read it out of a sense of-
I didn't know if I should read it,
because he wasn't my dad, he's their dad.
Yeah, he's your father-in-law.
I kind of wanted them to tell me
it was okay for me to read it,
which they did, and then I read it.
And of course I was gonna give it to mom.
I thought they would be
fine with me reading it.
I'm sure they would.
But I just wanted to cover my bases.
Got it.
Legal purposes.
In 1969, he told the story
of getting drafted into the Vietnam War,
because it was 1969.
They made you put down a preference area,
like what you would
prefer to concentrate in.
And he said, "Well, you drafted me,
you choose where I'm gonna go."
And they said, "Well,
you got to choose one of these things.
Are you interested in
infantry, transportation?"
And he was like, "Transportation.
I grew up on a farm.
I drive all types of things.
I'll do transportation."
And so he tells the story,
I'm not gonna read it of,
like everybody in the,
I'm sorry, I don't know the actual term,
the group of 80 people-
Platoon?
That are being put through basic training
and then getting their assignment.
The vast majority of people,
when they got their
assignment, it was Vietnam,
but his was Washington DC.
And he was like, there
must be some mistake.
Two people out of all 80,
it says Washington DC.
And he goes up there and the guy says,
"Well, you lucky duck.
You've been assigned to be a chauffeur
at the Pentagon for the Vietnam War."
Whoa.
Talk about dodging a bullet, or many.
It's like, he was, and it was kind of,
he was very fortunate.
And then he tells the
story of learning to drive
every piece of equipment in the army,
including tanks and
stuff, but then he was,
when he got his assignment
to go to the Pentagon,
he was driving senators and
all government officials
and military officials from the Pentagon.
He said, "I had to memorize everywhere
in Washington, DC like
the back of my hand.
I knew Washington DC better
than I knew Lillington."
So he's talking about that.
He says, "After a month
in service, moved,"
and I wanna read some of this
to give you an idea of how he wrote it.
He wrote it like he was talking.
"After a month in service,
moved out into an apartment
behind the Iwo Jima Statue,
and enjoyed it very much.
Would go over to Washington Monument
and run to the top several
nights a week, just for fun.
It was a tough run, 897 steps to the top.
We would look out when we got to the top,
then run back down.
The run down was much
easier than going up.
I think it was longer
going up than coming down."
Yep.
That's a joke because
it was the same route.
Right.
That was what made it funny.
Yeah, yeah, I'm tracking.
You gotta get a ticket to go in there now.
I know, unless you're like,
I guess if you're a soldier
and you have a uniform,
and you have access to
drive everybody around,
maybe you can just go,
you have a key and you can run up there.
I was just there recently,
and there's a whole complex that's added
to the side of one part of it
where there's security
things as you go through
and a little gift shop.
Just think about it,
back then, it was '69,
during the Vietnam War, he was running,
he was driving people
around, and for exercise,
running to the top of
the Washington Monument
multiple nights a week.
I'll never look at the Washington Monument
not think of that story.
Your papa-
Used to run 897 steps.
And I remember he would tell us
that story at some family gatherings.
So it's cool that those
things made it in here
and a lot more that I'm not gonna read.
But he talked about,
he started coaching at Cape
Fear Christian Academy.
And he taught the girls, taught,
he coached the girls' basketball team.
And they made it to the
state championship and lost.
But he was a very successful
coach from the beginning,
fresh out of the military and college.
So he would talk about,
he would tell these
stories of getting drafted,
of things like that, but
it was striking sometimes
how he would really hone in
on something very specific.
"1976, bothered by pollen.
From the mid-'70s, I was
always bothered by pollen.
My eyes would always turn
red and itch very bad.
I had to use many bottles of Visine.
Visine would just ease it off
for a few minutes, but not long.
During the '70s and '80s,
I had to wear a mask
while mowing the grass.
In the earlier '90s, after my divorce,
pollen bothered me for one year.
It is now 2016, and it has
not bothered me in 15 years.
Thank you, Lord.
I have not had any treatment
and do not take any meds for it.
It just does not bother me anymore."
Man, that's awesome.
I know, it's like-
Bothered by pollen.
Yeah, he was like, this is just a strange,
this is his way of saying,
this is an inexplicable,
potentially metaphysical,
or spiritual thing that happened to me.
Was I cured of pollen?
I would like to know.
Because you know me,
I go through a lot of eye
drops just to be on camera.
I've gotta put an eye drops,
or else everybody thinks I'm high.
Well, maybe you just
needed to get a divorce.
Let's read between the lines here.
Baby, I love you,
but we're getting divorced
because I'm bothered by pollen.
That's the only reason.
We can stay together.
We just need to legally divorce,
'cause that might be the key.
"1982, taught math in
prison for 12 years."
What?
He took a job through Central
Carolina Community College.
I know you love CCCC.
They ask him to substitute teach
at the Harnett County Correctional
Center, aka the prison.
And so he said, "I started,
and I quite liked it.
So I just kept teaching
there for 12 years."
He writes,
"What's the difference between
an inmate and an outmate?
The outmate is a person that
has not been caught yet."
Wow.
"The students have sports just
like we do out of prison."
'Cause he taught younger kids,
and then he taught adults in the prison.
So when he talks about the students,
well, he is talking about all prisoners.
"The students have sports,
just like we do out of prison.
I had a student that was
the weightlifting champion
for all of Eastern region of the US.
A prison weightlifting champion?
He was, no,
he was weightlifting champion
before he was in prison.
So this was a huge guy.
"I had him for two semesters.
After the two semesters,
he was back on the yard.
Every morning, as I came
across the prison yard,
he would meet me and ask,
'How's everything going?'
Some mornings, he would ask me
if anyone was giving me any trouble.
After a year or so, I
asked him one morning,
'Why do you ask me that
question about every morning?'
He quickly answered me.
'Mr. Cummings, I don't want anyone
to give you any trouble
or a difficult time.
You were fair to all
of us while in school,
and you deserve the same.
If anyone gives you any
trouble, you tell me,
and I will take care of them at night
when they are not in school.
They won't bother you anymore.'"
Wow.
Sounds like he's saying,
"Hey, if somebody's bothering
you, I'll kill them."
Yeah, that's what I'm
understanding from it.
He says, "I was looked after
in ways I didn't even know.
He never told me until I asked
why he asked me almost every morning
is anyone causing any trouble."
The way he'd write down his story-
Just to tie a bow on it.
Just in case you lost track.
He didn't let, it wasn't like I'm,
he had these experiences.
The way that he tells
them is so approachable,
it's so true to who he was.
I can hear him saying these things.
Like I said, these stories,
some of them, he would tell us,
and he wrote them down
how he would tell them.
It wasn't like, I gotta make
this into more than it is.
I've gotta make this memoir-able.
It wasn't about the writing of it.
It was about the experience of it.
And I love the fact that
nothing got in the way of him
sitting down at his computer
and writing this stuff down.
And it's such a treasure.
He kept going.
"And yes, working with
prisons was different,
but it's that way in real life.
People are all very different.
Some inmates and some out.
You have to learn to work
with all kinds of people in real life.
It may be in school, job, church,
community work, recreation,
factory, et cetera.
And I had the opportunity to work
with private school
kids, public school kids,
parents, coaches,
administration, and prisoners.
Youth prisons for three years,
and adult prisons for nine years.
Lots of great experiences and
worked with great friends,
staff and students."
It's like he had wisdom to share,
and it didn't have to be,
yeah, it didn't have to be souped up.
I just love the fact that it captured
this down to earth wisdom that he had.
And the fact that he was so goodhearted.
Every time that we,
every time you saw him,
he had a story to tell, he
had a smile on his face.
He was a special guy.
And he and mom were such a pair.
That's the thing that mom and I were
able to talk about and remembering,
'cause what I didn't tell
you was, my mom said,
"Can you print that off for me?"
And I'm like, "Well, your
printer doesn't work.
And I'm not about to start
becoming your IT guy.
That's not the main thing I'm here for.
But what I will do, mom,
is I'll read it to you."
So I started reading
it, and we would start,
we read through the whole thing.
I read it out loud to her.
She was like, "This is
kinda like a bedtime story."
And we got to talking about
everything that I was reading,
that we couldn't get through
all of it in one night.
And I had to stop, and I was
like, "Mom, it's getting late.
You're gonna have to go to bed.
And she was like, "No, no."
It's just like putting a kid to bed.
And so then the next night, she was like,
it got to be like 7:30, and she was like,
"You gonna read some more to me.
We gotta pick up where
you left off last night."
And I was like, "Well, I
gotta charge my phone first,
'cause we don't want it to
die in the middle of it."
And she had to wait 30 minutes.
She was so excited.
Couldn't plug it in.
I kind of wanted to mess with her.
I was like, "We gotta wait
until it charges, mom."
But yeah, it just struck me,
when we went back through his memories,
even though she got one
line in the whole thing,
and it was like the year
of their second marriage,
married for the second time.
Oh wow, man.
So I gotta to that point in the thing
and I read it to her.
Hold on, hold on.
Let me just say,
as the guy who was not willing
to print it out for her,
but willing to read it,
you could have embellished that.
Got married for the second time
to the love of my life.
I've thought about it.
But by this point in the reading of it,
I wanted to be true to it.
And plus, we both had an appreciation.
Mom busted out laughing.
She was like, "Now I don't feel so bad
about giving him such a
hard time writing a book."
Well, I think it's because he was
actively experiencing a
relationship with her,
and the stuff that he was writing down was
a little bit more about
things he was remembering.
And so much of it was through the lens
of teaching and coaching,
and it was that world, like 90%.
If it wasn't about pollen,
he wrote one line about
each kid being born too,
I will say that.
I think
Bothered by Pollen is
probably a better name
for the book than Time Line.
Right.
Sounds like a Robert
Frost thing or something.
Part of me feels, he wrote
so many other things,
but mom and I just got an appreciation
for how perfect they were for each other.
And how those 15-plus years,
I don't know, how many years
did they have together?
I can't remember.
Well, you just said right there.
What year did he say
married for the second time?
I didn't paste that into this.
I'm not looking at the entire document.
In 2002, he talked about a
near death experience he had
where he almost got crushed
by a dump truck because he,
he had a dump truck on his farm,
and he reached, it was up.
Oh God.
And it was a tank full of water.
And then he reached underneath
it to pull out something.
He was like a dummy.
I pulled this thing that I
thought was a loose wire.
And it tripped the whole thing,
and it's the whole, like-
The hydraulic.
Huge truck, just like the
whole dump truck slammed down.
And the next thing he knew,
he was standing beside it,
and he did not know what happened.
He just had a few scrapes on his chest,
but he wasn't hurt.
And somebody walked by and they said,
"What, Lewis, what happened to you?"
And he was white as a sheet.
And Lewis said, "Nothing."
And then the guy said, "Well,
you're white is a sheet."
And he said, "Well, I
almost got crushed by this.
And I don't know what happened."
But his original answer
was nothing happened,
because I guess technically
nothing happened.
But he talks about that
near death experience, and-
That doesn't coincide
when he stopped being bothered by pollen.
Nope.
It's like, that was 10 years later.
Yeah, and then in 2010,
he talked about how he was
diagnosed with polycythemia vera,
which is like, your body
makes too much blood.
So he had to go to the doctor and just-
Leak?
Leak a pin of blood every month or so.
But he said the way that he found out was,
they were doing a bunch of tests
and they started taking blood,
and he said as the blood
came out of the needle,
it fell in the bag like ketchup
falling out of a bottle.
Oh my gosh.
It doesn't come out unless you squeeze it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh oh.
How did you read that
without freaking out?
I've freaked out about it a bunch,
but I've read this a bunch now.
So it's like thick blood?
Thick blood.
Oh gosh.
That's when he decided to retire.
And he moved into he and mom's
phase of happiness together.
But he had given up
coaching for the most part,
and he signs the whole
thing happy, happy, happy.
Thank you, Lord.
Happy, happy, happy was the
Duck Dynasty catchphrase
that he modified into good,
good, good.
Good, good, good, yeah.
And there's so much more
there that is not my business
reading anymore of it publicly,
but I just wanted to do that
to honor him as a person.
But you can see how this got me thinking.
We should all be doing this.
You've got experience-
We should all have a timeline?
We should all be writing down
the things that happened to us.
He had these memories
treasured in his mind.
It was just the things
that, what happened to him,
the way that he was drafted,
and the near death experience,
and I guess the pollen too,
these were all things that were like,
and the people that he met,
and a lot of coaches
and basketball players
that I did not go into those details here,
were things that were
very important to him
and were kind of extraordinary.
Things that don't happen to a guy
who just is a farmer and a
teacher in rural Harnett County.
So he had this sense that
he lived a full life.
And it brought a tremendous amount
of comfort to all of us that read it.
And his kids, to me, to mom.
I read it to Christy and my
kids when they showed up.
We went back through it.
It was like, we were able to celebrate.
It's like, wow, he really had a,
he had a lot of treasures
in terms of memories.
So this gotten you thinking,
are you gonna start writing?
Well for us, I'm like,
that's kind of like the,
I don't know, the every man's application,
but we're not every
man, we're weird people.
We're weird people who have
this conversation on a podcast.
And we've documented so
much of our lives here.
It was the type of thing that, again,
when you were, week before last,
when you started talking
about your trip with Locke,
it's like, you shared that with me
and on this podcast with
everybody who's listening.
You're also sharing it with people
who would care to listen
after you're gone.
There's so much stuff out there,
and so many stories out there
in Chia Lincoln and Good Mythical Morning,
and especially this podcast
when we're actively
processing things that like,
we're storing up a
bunch of treasures here.
But honestly, I was like,
there's no way my kids
will ever listen to this.
First of all, there's way too much of it.
It's not like a Word document
that can be emailed to you after I die.
It's like, do I make a
after death playlist?
Do we need somebody to do that?
There's so much content from
us that it's overwhelming.
It's for our audience now.
But then I start thinking about,
are my grandkids gonna listen to this?
Are my great-great-grandkids
gonna listen to this?
Are they listening to it right now?
Oh, that's a thought.
Does it mean anything to me
to know that that's part of it?
You think this would make-
What is legacy?
I don't know if this
would make the playlist.
Maybe this would make the
Link history playlist,
because you're talking about the playlist,
and it's only appropriate
that it's so meta
that it just would make the playlist.
So that means I'm on the playlist.
So welcome to Link's
life history playlist.
You're in so much of it.
People are kind of annoyed.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, but-
Why do you insist on being
in everything that is my legacy?
They're gonna feel the same
way about my, now this is my,
this is the one video that's
in both of our playlists.
So welcome to my playlist,
and I'm sorry that he's here.
And even in the "Book of Mythicality,"
we devoted a whole chapter
two planning our funeral.
I'm not really talking about
planning the funeral and our,
what's, our obituary, we
wrote farcical obituaries.
We try to just embrace death in that way,
and the humor of it on this side.
But I'm talking less about
that and more about just,
we put out so much information
that our loved ones could benefit.
They can know us through all of this.
But it's so much that
I honestly don't think
it's just too intimidating.
Well-
It's too much.
So it's then it becomes nothing.
Well, I don't necessarily agree with that.
It makes me think a couple of things.
One is that, and we can come
back to this in a second.
I just wanna throw this out there.
'Cause the first thing I think of is,
what is the motivation for a legacy?
What is that related to?
What are we actually trying to accomplish?
Second thing is,
I have thought about
this aspect of my kids,
my grandkids, just how
people would remember me.
I tend, of course,
and most people who are entertainment
tend to think this to some degree,
but we tend to think that what
we have to say is important.
We're narcissistic enough
to not maybe get
diagnosed as a narcissist,
but narcissistic enough to feel
like we could have a podcast and a show,
and a so-and-so, and what we're saying-
I know, but I don't think it's important.
I think it's entertaining and engaging.
Well, but-
And connecting.
But I guess what I'm getting at is,
so I have journaled at different
rates on and off for years.
But as we have transitioned
more into this podcast
being so full of self-disclosure
and sort of story, summary,
and that kind of thing,
and also the stuff that we've done
on Good Mythical Morning over the years,
the frequency and the detail
of journaling has gone way down.
There was a point in my life
when I would start writing
in a journal entry,
and I was definitely writing it
as if someone was going
to find it someday.
I'm thinking about my grammar,
and I'm thinking about sounding smart
and eloquent and sounding
like a good writer.
And that has really gone away.
And also, with something
like the trip that I took with Locke,
that now I was able to sit down
within a week of getting back,
write down all the little
things that stand out in my mind
as being compelling to
remember and to talk about,
and then I talked about them
for an hour and a half or
however long that podcast was.
And so now I've kind of put it out there,
and if I wanted to re-access it
at some point to remember what I,
'cause it has, there's
a little bit of this,
I'm never going to
remember it as precisely
as I did a week after it happened
and when I told the story.
So you think about it in
terms of personal recall.
You're never gonna-
No, no, no, no.
That's one aspect.
It's just one aspect of it.
But you don't,
but you honestly don't think
you're ever gonna re-listen to it, right?
No, no, but I think that Locke will.
The idea that,
I think there are certain
pieces where it's like,
okay, after I'm gone,
Locke will listen to those two podcasts
of the two road trips that we had
in the span of four months.
Does he know they exist though?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, he knows they exist.
Okay.
I don't know if he listens to them now.
He's an 18-year-old kid who's
got a bunch of stuff going on.
He's like, my dad made stuff.
But he will, he will at some point.
Either when I'm old or when I'm gone.
You know what I'm saying?
So I do think about that, but I,
so I kind of feel like we've
got it covered in one sense.
Now, to answer your question
about the logistics of it,
you're probably, if
you're interested in this,
if you're legitimately interested
in somebody doing this,
I do think it's like a paid intern
working for literally
months to take everything
that you've ever said about yourself
and put it into a playlist
or edit it together, yes,
I think that that could
be a worthy exercise
if you wanna catalog your life,
because you've talked
about so much of your life,
and then we'd probably get
one intern to do both of us.
But-
So I do think the only way,
it's just so intimidating
to have a curated guide to,
Link's dead, and you
wanna be sad about it,
but you wanna also be happy about it.
And you want, like-
I think it-
This is a good-
I think a sampling is enough.
Sampling is probably-
I think you get,
we kind of say the same types of things
over and over again.
Like a guy.
Ah, yeah, some funny things happened.
I don't think it's, to me,
there's one thing that's like,
the process of mourning and letting go,
but celebrating and hanging
on to who, like in this case,
who Lewis was as a person,
who he was to me, who he was to mom,
who he was to students and prisoners.
It coalesced in my brain,
like everything kind of came together.
I wish I would've read
it while he was alive,
and we could have talked about it.
When he said I'm writing it, yeah,
it was like, let me read what you got.
But it's just one of those
things where it's like,
okay, it's a work in progress.
But-
Go ahead.
I do think that there's
another way to think,
so that's one place to
think about it, is that,
hey, I'm mourning, I'm remembering,
and I'm not just eulogizing,
but commemorating.
So I feel like my love for
Lewis is kind of commemorated
in this experience of reading this thing.
But there's another
experience that I think about
that's like my grandkids'
kids would be like,
"Oh yeah, back when videos
used to be on the internet,
and this is how technology used to work,
your great-great-grandfather,
that guy who's like,
he's so old, he's scary to look at."
Do you think you're gonna
have great-great-grandkids?
You're gonna get some sort of elixir?
Yeah, man.
Okay.
Well, yeah, I guess you're right.
The dead guy.
You know, the one that's
just a brain in a vat,
with the glasses on the
outside of the glass.
Yeah, who knows how I'm
still gonna stick around.
Grandpa Link.
Or I'm gone.
And it's like, you can watch these things.
You're gonna have to get a
different type of screen,
and it's not gonna be
downloaded to your brain.
I know it's gonna be frustrating,
and you have to scrub through it
on this old device or something,
or I don't know, maybe
it's been brainitized.
You make a good point,
because if they could just download
all the history to their brain,
then they actually don't have
to watch it and watch all that content.
Talking matrix?
Yeah.
Download.
But I think that's another use case of-
I've been thinking this.
All of this crap is at like,
all this content that we're
putting out into the world,
It's like, what if you were, I don't know,
It would be like watching,
like if Andy Griffith was
my great-great-grandfather,
and I'm like, well, you gotta watch
this show called the Andy Griffith Show.
He was a comedian and he made this sitcom.
What's a sit, okay, don't worry about it.
Just watch it.
You won't find it funny-
My question is why.
So what is the motivation
for us as living people
who are trying to leave
a legacy once we're dead?
And what is the motivation,
or what do you think the purpose,
ultimate purposes for someone
who's left behind to read it?
'Cause I was thinking about,
I was recently thinking about
my grandfather, my dad's dad.
Now, both of my
grandfathers, my dad's dad,
who I met just a couple
of times in my life,
and then my mom's dad,
who I never met because he died
when my mom was in college.
And then I had like a step-granddad,
who was the closest thing
I had to a granddad,
but, you know, but I've
been thinking about them,
the ones that I didn't know
well, and I'm just like,
everything I know about them is
through the lens of my parents.
And I found myself wondering,
what were they really like,
and how much of it has been shaped
by just the perception
that my parents had?
And then I was like, why?
Why do I wanna know about them?
Why do I wanna know that?
'Cause you feel a connection.
There's a blood connection to like,
there's a part of my DNA
that was in this guy.
I am who I am at least in part
because of them, for sure.
Think about if you could watch a video,
a one hour and a half
video of your grandfather
talking about his struggle
with spirituality.
That would be fascinating.
And just to say, look at his mannerisms.
I do that.
I sound like that.
I have this instinct to talk
about things in this way.
And so did he.
All of a sudden, you have this
like connection of lineage.
I've never really been one to,
I'm not one of those family tree people.
I've just never been inspired
to look into lineage.
But that is fascinating.
And if there was a video
of my great-grandfather-
If we just get a video-
In his internet prime talking
about it, I'd be like,
oh, I gotta see a little bit of that.
Of course, I would love
to experience that from
long dead relatives.
But then maybe you get
some sort of insight,
because there's wisdom.
To me, it's like,
is there wisdom that could be passed down
a few more generations,
because so much has been recorded of us?
I would hope so.
Especially on Ear Biscuits,
but there's also a lot
of us cutting a fool,
that would just be a trip to watch.
People found this funny.
It's like, what?
Yeah, people find it funny, but-
Some people did.
A lot of people didn't.
All of the stuff that we eat
on Good Mythical Morning is like,
it's a preservation of pop culture,
in a way that there's few,
there's other videos that got it,
but in terms of a complete
catalog of pop culture,
especially when it comes
to food, like snacks,
think about like, we go on eBay,
and get all these old discontinued snacks,
and eat them from decades ago.
But think about a century from now,
we are conveying an experience
of eating snacks from the 2010s, 2020s.
Is that valuable to the
Library of Congress?
They put like Wu-Tang clan
in the National Archives.
I kind of feel like maybe
one day we'll be in-
Okay, but here's my question.
GMM will be in the National Archives.
But-
For eating snacks.
But why do we want that to be a-
I just think that's cool.
I don't want that to be the case-
But no, you kind of do, though.
Well, I'm not doing it for that reason,
'cause I just thought of it.
Well, no, no, no, but I'm just saying,
what is the motivation to, yeah, okay,
there's an altruistic version,
which is like, maybe my descendants
will gain some insight about themselves.
Yes, of course, that's awesome.
Sins of the father type thing.
That's rewarding to think about.
But don't you think that everyone
has a tendency to want to be remembered,
and it's the same thing that
keeps you wanting to be alive?
We don't wanna die.
We don't wanna go away.
And lots of people,
probably the majority
of people in the world,
definitely the majority of
the people in the world,
believe that they will continue to exist
in some form after they die.
I don't know what I think about that.
Obviously, everyone wants
to continue to exist.
But what if this expression
of consciousness is
contained in this lifetime
and then it's over?
First of all, there won't
be any ego post-death
to appreciate or relish in the fact
that you are being remembered.
Locke and I had this
interesting conversation
on our road trip, now
that I think about it,
that is strangely related to this.
'Cause he essentially asked the question,
I don't remember the
specifics, but it was,
"Would you, if you could choose,
your life is going to be great,
and you're gonna get to do the
things that you want to do,
and accomplish the things
that you want to accomplish,
and live a long life.
But five years after you die,
your reputation is gonna be ruined
because they find something out about you.
Even if it didn't happen.
But let's just say that somebody says
something about you that wasn't true,
but your name-
Post-death smear campaign.
Your name becomes associated with just,
oh, we don't talk about it.
We don't talk about grandpa
because of so and so.
Okay.
And Locke was like,
"Would you-"
Or what?
I'm just saying, if you, okay,
if somebody came to
you right now and said,
you can have what you want,
you can have health, and life,
and success.
But the trade off is-
But just so you know,
five years after you die-
Okay, yeah, I got it.
I'll tell you what I say after you-
My knee-jerk reaction
is I would go for it.
I just feel like the
reputation is overrated.
I'm just concerned
about how it might impact
my progeny's opportunity.
Well, that's what I told him.
I said, the first thing
that comes to mind is,
I don't want your life and Shepherd's life
and your mom's life to suck because-
Of a smear campaign.
Yeah.
But if you remove that,
so let's just say it's
five generations later,
that your name is gonna be synonymous
with something crazy,
hateful, or just whatever.
How does it make you feel?
Okay, Locke was like, "I don't care,
because I won't have the ability to care,"
but really, if you could
choose, if you could choose,
and let's say nobody
that currently you love
and know is gonna be affected,
but five generations from now,
are you really telling me
that you don't care about
your name being smeared?
I have to know, what
am I choosing against?
You gotta tell, just a
crappy life, a horrible life?
No, no, I'm changing the
scenario now, and saying that,
I'm coming to you, and I
say five years from now,
five generations from
now after you're dead,
either you're gonna be,
your name's gonna be
remember for what you did,
or there's gonna be a smear campaign.
You're obviously gonna
choose what you did, but why?
Why do you care?
'Cause one thing is like, do you care?
I only have something to
gain, I guess is my point.
What do you have to gain?
You won't exist.
The knowledge now that I won't be smeared
five generations from now.
Right, but even, when
I think about things,
like I don't want to
die naked or something,
you know what I'm saying?
I don't wanna die in an embarrassing way.
When you think about, oh man,
if I die and I'm wearing
this pair of underwear
that I just took a crap in or something,
there's a part of me that's like my ego
feels like it's trying to
reach past my existence.
Okay.
And so I say all that to make the point
to come back to what we're
talking about, which is,
it's difficult for me to
separate that tendency
for my ego to wanna live
beyond my consciousness,
from my desire to leave a legacy.
Because it is a lot about me.
And then I kind of end up being
in this place where I'm like,
ah, I have so much to be
thankful for in terms of,
so much of what I've done and said
and the things that I'm
proud of are out there.
And I don't really have
to think about this.
I don't have to think about
what my memoir would be,
because it's kind of
already being written.
I don't-
So it sort of takes care of itself.
For me, I get excited
about my great-grandkids
who would never know me,
or know me as this old guy
who might be an invalid or something,
or great-great-grandkids
who will never know me,
being able to know me in a
sense, and say, you know what,
I could have been friends with that guy.
I don't know, that just, it just seems,
it just warms my heart a little bit.
And I think there's legitimacy in that.
Yeah, so I don't think about
like on a societal level.
I know that we're doing good work.
I know it has a positive impact on people.
And when I say it, I do start to think,
and I guess get excited about,
some people would still have
this taste for it generations from now.
They might, you're probably right.
They would watch Good
Mythical Morning and say,
"You found this funny?
You found this entertaining?"
But maybe that's not true.
I could sit down and watch
the Andy Griffith Show
right now and my heart
could be warmed by that.
So that does make me happy.
But in terms of like,
I guess now I'm in such a familial zone
with coming off the
funeral and everything,
I'm thinking a number of
things, which is like,
I'm thinking more about
dying than living forever,
like death with dignity type thing.
And I started to have
those type of thoughts.
But also, people who,
like generations, like family members,
being able to have some connection with me
and gain some wisdom from
me that I would just hope
that they could glean somehow
through reading between the lines.
And I don't-
Of this podcast.
And I don't think there's,
I completely agree.
And I don't think there's
anything wrong with that.
And I'm not trying to say
that the element of ego
that is in what you just
said as well is a bad thing.
We can't help-
Sure.
The fact that we want to leave a legacy
that is positive is a good thing
that's built into the human psyche.
Because if it wasn't, then you would do
some crazy shit right
at the end of your life,
just because, you know what I'm saying?
We actually want to die,
most people wanna die
well, wanna leave a legacy.
And I think that because
you have the ability
to think about the future benefit
that someone else will receive.
And even if it makes you
feel good because, oh,
I'm proud that I could leave a legacy
that they will benefit from.
I don't think there's
anything wrong with that.
It's just, those are the things
that come to mind when I think about,
that can be taken too far.
There's an unhealthy level of that
when you're so concerned
about what you're doing
and how people will
remember you in ways that,
it's the old adage.
You can't take anything with you.
I've never seen a hearse
with a U-Haul attached to it.
You can't take anything with
you, but you can leave a lot.
Oh.
You know what I'm saying?
I've heard that before.
Who told you that?
Not you.
But I also like the idea
of, okay, when I die,
I would love to know that there are still
some mythical beast out
there who are active enough,
hopefully I'll die a
long time time from now,
so it'll be surprising that
there's active mythical beasts
who are putting together
just like a montage.
People still watch "Golden Girl."
I just wanna-
Put down a-
People still watch "Golden
Girls" for comfort.
I have to believe that
somebody out there is
gonna watch GMM for comfort.
But I believe that there
will be fan montages
that will be passed
around on whatever version
of the internet exists in the future.
Hopefully, the distant
future after I pass.
And the sadness that they experience
in me being gone will be
overwhelmed and eclipsed
by the comfort in knowing
that I lived my life
to the fullest and they connected with it.
I agree.
I wholeheartedly agree.
It does feel good to know
that that will happen.
But one interesting thing
as a closing thought
that might make this all
very unsettling for you,
is that our legacies are linked.
Is inextricable, is that a word?
Yeah, whoever doesn't die first.
So if I die and you live on,
and you do something that is,
if you just tarnish your
legacy, you tarnish my legacy,
because people can't, you know,
and vice versa.
How did we solve this
in the "Book of Mythicality" by,
when you read the obituaries,
you realized that one of us
inadvertently killed the other one
through some strange turn of events.
That was a fun chapter, but-
That's how we solved it.
But that's an interesting thing is
that so much of what
people experience from you,
what your great-great-grandkids
experience,
they are forced to experience me as well.
And we basically have that responsibility
for one another whoever dies first.
You got to-
To make the playlist?
Well, to hire an intern
to make the playlist, yes.
But what I'm saying is to make sure
that the legacy is not
tarnished, I'm just saying.
And I'm taller, so I'm
probably gonna die first.
So this is probably on you.
Okay, yeah, I'm not worried about it.
That's my worry.
Sorry.
If I'm not present-
Yeah, man.
And maybe there's a
livestream at some point.
Now you know how Christy feels
every day when I come to work.
30 years from now,
something comes out wrong.
What's he gonna do at work today?
On a livestream, and
you tarnish our legacy.
And I'm just like, I'm up there in heaven.
Damn it, I can't do anything about this.
Oh, but you're watching it.
Yeah, I'm watching it on Link TV.
You're seeing all of it.
So write your own timeline if you want to,
if you were inspired to do so.
Bothered by pollen.
Let us know about your
experience with pollen.
#EarBiscuits.
What does this make you think of?
How are you processing this?
Is it making you cringe?
Is it giving you ideas?
I really don't know.
That's why #EarBiscuits exists.
And why do you wanna leave a legacy?
What kind of legacy do
you want to leave and why?
Oh gosh, we got deep.
There's gotta be more of these podcasts.
#EarBiscuits.
Do you have a rec?
I do have a rec.
Not related to anything.
Switch it up.
I'm going to recommend a hot sauce.
Okay.
It's a hot sauce
that I've been putting on multiple things.
This is exciting, this is different.
It is Marie Sharp's,
now she has a whole
lot of different stuff.
The original hot sauce,
which is pretty doggone hot,
it is from Belize.
And it is habanero.
And in Belize, they add
carrots to the hot sauce,
which gives it a really good flavor.
Now, let me say something about this.
And you may remember when we-
$10 On Amazon.
Much cheaper than that
in the grocery store.
And it's probably available
in most grocery stores.
When we did a hot sauce taste
test on Good Mythical Morning,
we tried Melinda's Hot Sauce.
And Josh said this at the time,
I don't know what made it to air.
But the story of this hot
sauce is that this woman,
Marie Sharp, was in Belize,
and her husband was a farmer.
He was growing habaneros,
and she started making
hot sauces out of it.
Everybody was like, "This is great.
We're gonna make,
we want to start selling your hot sauce."
And she says, "I wanna call it Melinda's."
And it was named after the
farm or something on the farm.
The company that she was
working with copyrighted
or trademarked Melinda's
and started Melinda's
the hot sauce company,
which is actually bigger
than Marie Sharp's,
and sells a bunch of hot sauces.
And we had it on the show,
and that's why I feel a
little bit bad about this,
and basically took this woman for a ride.
So you're trying to make it right
with this recommendation.
And then Marie Sharp was like,
I gotta go back and start from scratch,
and I'm gonna make my own hot sauces.
And now she makes her own hot sauce.
And she has a bunch of
different varieties.
Again, I like the original.
And she has reasons for why she thinks
hers is better than Melinda's.
I actually haven't
tried them side by side,
but just out off principle,
I'm a Marie Sharp's man,
and it is spicy, but
I've been putting it on,
I've been putting it on
everything, and I just love it.
It's got a complex flavor and some heat.
So I think probably any of
the varieties are great,
but if you're gonna get started somewhere,
start with just the original hot.
I love how the-
In the white-wrapped bottle.
The bottle gives a lot of the
story of how she makes it,
but the last sentence is,
"Produced in the fertile
paradise of Belize.
Her red habanero is considered
to be the hottest of pepper known to man."
That's questionable.
Well, that's not true, but-
"Marie has spent many years cultivating
a habanero worthy of her recipe.
She has succeeded."
She has succeeded.
There's just something about it.
Something about it.
Marie Sharp's Hot Sauce.
It's got her picture on
the side of the bottle too.
I love that.
All right.
Marie Calendar, I mean, Marie Sharp's.
I Belize you will enjoy it.
#EarBiscuits.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.